e
l'avant avec certaines réformes
sociales. Jean-Michel Leprince.
(klaxons)
- Rafael Boric devient à 35 ans
le plus jeune président
du Chili. Leader étudiant
des manifestations de 2011,
il rebondit sur la révolte
populaire de 2dadadans les rues
du Chili pour offrir
un programme progressiste
dans un pays qui vit encore
dans l'héritage économique de
la dictature d'Augusto Pinochet.
Son adversaire, José Antonio
Kast, lui code la victoire
un peu plus d'une heure après
la fermeture des bureaux
de vote. Par Tweeter, il dit
qu'il a appelé et félicité
son adversaire pour "son grand
trhehehe, et que le président
élu mérite respect et
collaboration constructive."
D'origine allemande, l'ultra-
conservateur Kast assume
emememement son admiration
pour Jair Bolsonaro et Donald
Trump. Un populiste qui de façon
surprenante est arrivé en tête
au premier tour de l'élection.
Une forte participation,
le vote des jeunes, a creusé la
différence en faveur du candidat
de gauche. Il veut réformer le
système de pension de retraites
pré é é é qui pèse lourd
sur les revenus de nombreux
chiliens, ainsi que les systèmes
de santé et d'éducation.
La révolte populaire de 2019
pour plus de justice sociale
a conduit à l'élection d'une
assemblée constituante.
Celle-ci doit rédiger une
nouvelle constitution pour
remplacer celle que le Chili
a hérité de la dictature et
qui sera soumise àenenenenendum
probablement en septembre 2022.
José Antonio Kast aurait tout
fait pour torpiller le projet,
Gabriel Boric lui assure un
avenir. Il devra cependant
gouverner avec une forte
opposition de droite au
congrès qui démontre que
celle-ci est encore puissante
au Chili, 30 ans après
la fin de la dictature.
Jean-Michel Leprince
R